Pedophiles are really tough people.
They like to annoy the kids, that's crazy.
It's their favorite thing.
I mean, it's crazy if you take the risk of being a pedophile.
Not to mention the damage you do, but the risk ...
You can't be worse than a pedophile.
But they do it anyway.
From which we can conclude that it must be really great.
From their point of view. Not from ours. But from theirs.
It must be amazing.
They risk so much ...
Is the joke offensive?
Some people think so.
What if they look at the victims? Or what if the victims' parents are watching?
It's such a perverted thing that happens to people,
and I know the comics are trying to push the boundaries
and sometimes they risk, sometimes the risk doesn't work out
but I think something like rape is not funny
and he is smart enough to come up with something else.
What do we really ask when we ask a question
whether the joke, tweet or picture is offensive?
We don't ask if he insulted someone, did he?
No. We ask if what he said was morally correct.
How can anyone decide?
How do we know if a joke is morally wrong?
I don't think this is just going anywhere.
I know someone who was raped in three years, in three years!
There's nothing funny about it.
No club, no one should make fun of it.
This woman thinks it's a joke effect
because rape of children is such a sensitive subject.
Because the suffering is so terrible and long lasting,
and so a joke on this subject can suffer as a shrink
on the contrary, bring it back.
The rape of children should be completely avoided by comedy.
This is certainly a good argument.
It cannot be the goal of comedy to cause suffering to victims.
But that was definitely not Louis's goal.
It wasn't his intention.
It's all about one thing: about intent. It's just a purpose.
In this performance, Ricky Gervais questions the desire to be moral
the joke judge, and instead suggests that we should be primarily concerned with the comic of the intention.
Louis's intention was to use a comedy to make us think
the approach of society to the topic and treatment of pedophilia.
Maybe it suggests that we are not addressing this issue,
we are comforting our normality, even though we know the complex sexual desires
pedophiles are not their own choice.
They never forgive them, nor do they advocate their act.
It goes without saying that the rape of a child should follow
the greatest contempt and retribution.
I think this was the intention, and many people thought about ours
smug accusations of own grandeur and fear of impunity for sexuality
in a civilized society.
Jokes are really well designed to deliver such messages.
They get us into the subconscious and break the barriers that make us different
it prevents thinking about the threat to our comfort.
I must say that I totally disagree with Ricky when he says that it is up to the intention.
Apparently not.
We must be aware of both intended and unintended
consequences of what we say.
We know too often people with privileges define the boundaries of morality,
without thinking about the different experiences of people
who have been subjected by others, are thrown to the edge of society or worse.
These discussions about political correctness and comedy began to occur more often
with the advent of the Internet that gives people the opportunity to express themselves.
I am always amazed at how easy it is to divide the arguments into two camps.
One side comes up with concern about the joke,
and the other will defend the joke at any cost,
scold at the never-ending penetration of internet police
and fighters for social justice into freedom of speech.
They just want to use words like racism, sexism or prejudice
but they don't even know what they're talking about.
All this tells me that morality is chaotic.
Shifts and changes.
People often say that something has already been on the line
but there are no lines in morality.
It's a land of no one, a hazy edge of really difficult questions.
I can see that great comedians are like detectives.
Look at Luther or any other criminal
And you will see it as a company
we do not mind when detectives sometimes bend rules for greater good.
This is because we understand that justice is, like morality, abstract.
Detectives are trained to move on the edge of justice
and we allow them to do so.
I think we should let our great comedians move
on the edge of morality.
I don't know what society decides who can move there and who doesn't.
There is no easy answer.
I think that when a comedian is admitted to professional high circles,
somehow we know it.
Of course I know how unsatisfactory this answer is.
We can all look at the purpose of the joke, their effect,
whether we laugh or not.
But if we want to allow our morality to evolve, we must leave it
Comics move close to things that are unpleasant to us or seem bad to us.